que exercices d'assouplissement et
d'étirements c'est désormais le béaba
des compagnons avant de prendre leur
poste de travail
ces élèves de classe de troisième ils
ont 13 14 ans vont s'imprégner des
réalités d'un chantier de ces outils
désirant de surprises en découvertes
c'est contre le ton de celui qui mène ma
visite est celui d'un pédagogue
on a quelque chose un gros truc orange
on s'appelle comment ça et une grue
donc ça c'est notre outil principal et
pour travailler
qu'est-ce qu'on fait qu'une grue
transport des objets c'est lourd j'ai 14
ans et mon père et routiers qu'est ce
que tu veux faire plus tard
vétérinaire je savais pas que j'allais
faire autant d'étapes pour la
construction d'un bâtiment qu'est ce que
tu veux faire plus tard
architecte alors architecte c'est un
métier d'homme ou c'est un métier de
femme ni deux j'ai 13 ans ma mère est
professeur des écoles et mon père
informaticien est sur le terrain me
montre à tous les métiers que je ne
connaissais pas avant
après la visite de chantier placez une
autre salle de travail
présentation du projet en 3d sans
oublier les appels du pied espérer
susciter des vocations comète c'est un
projet structurant les chiffres parlent
d'eux mêmes un palais des sports 2000
place un parc d'exposition
seize mille mètres carrés de surface au
sol une salle de sport capacité
d'accueil
dix mille places de poids vous en mettre
plein les yeux